a washing machine video game and what's
that dress made of cow nipples oh it is
Vsauce Kevin here this is my flow to
wear someone else's face a pair of
programmers developed this real-time
video face tracking and modifying
application it allows the user to
overlay a face from a photo in real-time
video so you can look like creepy
versions of Brad Pitt Paris Hilton or
just do this you may have heard of the
big dog a quadruped military companion
developed by DARPA while Boston Dynamics
is now working on Bulldog a larger
version capable of carrying 400 pounds
of supplies last 24 hours and able to
trek 20 miles mostly it just reminds me
of Metal Gear Solid a robot that's been
known to lace footballs and make paper
planes can now Beall grapes there are
over a thousand da Vinci surgical robots
worldwide and this one has performed 450
prostate cancer removals a robot that da
Vinci himself would be proud of is the
interactive robotic painting machine it
uses input from the environment to make
decisions on how to paint and apparently
if there's no one else in the room it
will make the decisions by itself giant
onion NASA is releasing new images of
the Sun taken from the Solar Dynamics
Observatory the SDO is studying how the
inside of the Sun works and how energy
is stored and release in the sun's
atmosphere and apparently this is what
former NASA employees do after they've
been laid off the trace achill is part
bike part car and it's the first race
engineered street-legal three-wheeled
vehicle the floating orchestra is
controlled with an iPhone it allows each
of the 19 spheres to become an
orchestral instrument that increases in
volume as the sphere itself Rises
magnets and music collide with the
magnetic cello it uses a magnetic rod
instead of a horsetail bow that induces
voltage in a coil where the bridge would
be the strings are resistive ribbons
that control a second voltage and here's
twinkle twinkle little star
researchers at UC Berkeley have
reconstructed images from a person's
brain activity subjects were shown
YouTube videos while their brains were
monitored and scientists later
reconstructed approximate images of
those videos from the brain data so yeah
this video shows how teri Garrett who is
blind plays the legend of zelda ocarina
of time using only the sound effects and
an advancement system he created using
save states find the link below
finally here's an epic stop-motion video
detailing the progressions of a tattoo
and I'm gonna leave you with fossilized
dinosaur vomit
there are four clues in the description
of this video the first person to answer
all four correctly will be our genius of
the week so good luck and as always
thanks for watching